- Un rendez-vous attendu,
russe en Ukraine : la rencontre
de leaders politiques alliés
en quête de soutien.
La Chine dit vouloir assumer
son rôle de superpuiRuRuRuRuRuRr
de la stabilité dans un monde
où règne le chaos.
Vladimir Poutine, lui, salue
juste et équilibrée, adoptéepart
en Ukraine.
En retour, soutien
à la politique de la Chine
unique et dénonciation
à Taïwan le mois dernier;
de la provocation américaine,
selon lui.
Les deux leaders autoritaires
Vladimir Poutine et Xi Jinpisosr
l'Organisation de coopération
de Shanghai, dont le Kazakhstan,
le Pakistan et l'Inde sont aussi
en sont des partenaires.orororos
de front anti-occidental.
Il s'agit ddéplacement hors dee
depuis le début de la pandémie
de COVID-19 pour Xi Jinping.
Son périple a commencé
au Kazakhstan, pays
où il a lancé en 2013 après
son accession au pouvoir
projet d'investissement dans les
infrastructurernrnrnrnationales.
Selon cet analyste, c'est
une façon pour Xi Jinping
d'annoncer la continuité,
à un mois du congrès du Parti
cotetetete chinois, qui devrait
lui accorder un troisième mandat
historique.
La Chine cherche à gagner
davantage en influn n n n Asie
centrale, selon lui, profitant
de l'affaiblissement desosososo.
Xi Jinping et Vladimir Poutine
se retrouveront au prochain
sommet du G20 au mois
en Indonésie. Ce face-à-face
av l l l leaders mondiaux aura
lieu au moment où les tensions
entre l'Occident eprprprprprprps
chinois et russe sont
à leur plus haut niveau.
Ici Philippe Leblan